in Moses, when We sent him to Pharaoh with clear authority, he turned away with
his might and said, "A magician or a madman." So We seized him and his soldiers and threw them into the sea, while he was blameworthy. And in '
Ad, when We sent upon them the barren wind, which left nothing it
came upon but made it barren. And
in Thamud, when it was said to them, "Enjoy yourselves for a time," but they defied the
command of their Lord, so the thunderbolt seized them while they were looking on. And they could not rise, nor could they defend themselves. And
the heaven and the
people of Noah before them—indeed, they were a people—indeed, they were a people who were defiantly disobedient. And
the heaven—We constructed it with might, and indeed, We are ever-ready. And the earth—We have spread it out, and how excellent a spreader We are! And of
everything We created pairs—that you may remember. So
flee
to God. Indeed, I am to you from Him a clear warner. And
do not associate with God another deity. Indeed, I am to you from Him a clear
warner. Likewise, there came not to those before them any
messenger except they said, "A magician or a madman. Has he enjoined it upon us?" Rather, they are a
people—rather, they are a
transgressing people. So turn away from them, for you are not to be blamed. And
remind, for indeed, the reminder benefits the believers. And I did not
create the jinn and the jinn.  [Singing] And
mankind only worship Me. I do not
want from them any provision, nor do I want them to feed Me. Indeed, it is
Allah who is the Provider, the Possessor of strength, the Firm.
And those who have wronged will have a punishment like the punishment of their companions, so let them
not be impatient. So woe to those who disbelieve from their
Day which they are promised. In
the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. [Clears throat] And the
Mount,
and a Book
covered
on parchment unrolled, and the
frequented House, and the
raised roof, and the
overflowing sea. Indeed, the
punishment of your Lord will surely come to pass; there is no repelling it. On the Day when
the sky will be in violent motion and the
mountains will move swiftly, then woe on that Day to the deniers. Allah is the
Greatest.
[Clears throat]
[Cough]
Allah hears those who praise Him.
Allah is the Greatest.
[Snoring sounds] Allah is the Greatest. Allah is the Greatest.
Praise be to Allah, Lord of the worlds, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, Master of the Day of Judgment.
You alone we worship, and You alone we ask for help. Guide us to the
straight path. [Clears throat] The path of those upon whom
You have bestowed favor, not of those who have evoked [Your] anger or of those who are astray.
Amen. So woe on that Day to the deniers, who
are in idle talk playing. On
the Day they are called to the Fire of Hell, [they will be called], "This is the Fire
which you used to deny. Is this
magic?"  Or do you
not see? So pray, and be patient
or impatient, it is all the same to
you. You are only being recompensed for what
you used to do. Indeed, the righteous will be
in gardens and
pleasure,
enjoying what their Lord has given them. And their Lord will inflict upon them the punishment of
Hell. [They will be told], “Eat and drink in good health for what you used to do,”
reclining on thrones arranged in rows. And We will pair them with fair-
eyed maidens. And those who believed and whose descendants followed them in
faith - We will join with them their descendants, and We will
not deprive them of anything of their deeds.
Every person is responsible for what he has
earned. And We
will provide them with fruits and
meat of what they desire. And there will circulate among them young boys [who will attend to them] as if they were
pearls well-preserved. And they will
approach one another, questioning each other. They will
say, “Indeed, we were before, among our families, fearful [of Hellfire], but
God conferred favor upon us and protected us from the torment of the scorching wind. Indeed, we used to
supplicate to Him before. Indeed, He is the Beneficent, the Merciful.” So
remind, for by the favor of
your Lord, you are neither a soothsayer nor a madman.
Or do they say, “A poet for whom we await a misfortune of death?” Say, “
Wait, for I am with you among those who wait.”
Do their dreams command them to do
this, or are they a transgressing people?
Or do they say, "He has fabricated it"? Rather, they
believe. Then let
them produce a statement like it, if they are truthful. Or were they
created from nothing? Or are they the creators? Or did
they create the heavens and the earth? Rather, they are not certain. Or do they possess the
treasuries of your Lord? Or are they the controllers? Or do they have a ladder by which they listen? Then let their listener bring forth a clear proof. Or does He have daughters
while you have sons? Or do
you ask them for a reward, so they are burdened with debt?
[Clears throat]
Or do they possess knowledge of the unseen, so they write it down? Or do they
intend a plot? But those who disbelieve are the ones who are plotted against.
Or do they have a god other than Allah? Exalted is Allah above what they associate with Him. And if they
see a fragment of the sky falling, they say, "It is but a mass of
clouds." So leave them to plunge into falsehood. Leave them to plunge into falsehood
until they meet their Day in which they will be struck down. The Day when their plot will
not avail them at all, nor will they be
helped. The Day when their plot will not avail them at all,
nor will they be helped. And indeed, for
those who have wronged, there is a punishment
before that, but most of them do not know. And be patient for the judgment of
your Lord, for indeed, you are in Our sight. And glorify Him
Praise your Lord when you rise, and
glorify Him during the night, and
glorify Him at the end of the night, and at the setting of the stars.
people
learn how
[music]
God hears those who praise Him.
God is the Greatest, God is the Greatest, God is the Greatest, God is the Greatest. And
prayers and good things and the mercy of God and
His blessings.
Peace be upon you and the mercy of God. Peace be upon you and
the mercy of God. The dialect of the
surveyor.
That was really
got the Egyptian
war.
Yeah.
David w
was
that.
Praise be to Allah,
Allah is the Greatest,
Lord of the Worlds, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, Master of the Day of Judgment.
You alone we worship, and You alone we ask for help. Guide us to the straight path, the path of
those upon whom You have bestowed favor, not of those who have evoked [Your] anger or of those who are astray.
Amen. By the
star when it sets, your companion has not gone astray, nor has he fallen, nor does he
speak from [his own] desire. It is not but a revelation revealed. He was
taught by one mighty in power, possessor of strength. He rose to the highest horizon,
then drew near and came down, until he was at a distance of two bow-lengths or nearer. And He revealed
to His servant what He revealed. The heart did not lie about what it saw. So will you dispute with him
over what he saw? And he certainly saw him another time at the Lote Tree of the Utmost Boundary, near which is the Garden of
Refuge, when there covered the heavens that which covered them. The sight did
not
swerve,
nor did it transgress. He certainly saw of the greatest signs of his Lord. So have you considered al-Ilah and al-Uzza and the third [of them]? For you is the male, and for Him is the female. That is when He divides it into portions. They are but names which you have named, you and your fathers. Allah has not revealed any authority for them. They follow not except conjecture and what they desire.  And indeed,
guidance has come to them from their Lord. Or does man have whatever
he wishes? To Allah belongs the Hereafter and the first life. And how many angels are there in the heavens whose intercession will not avail at
all,
except after
Allah has given permission to whom He wills and is pleased with. Indeed,
those who do not believe in the Hereafter
name the angels with female names, and they have no
knowledge of it. They follow only conjecture,
and conjecture does not diminish the truth at all. So
turn away from whoever turns away from Our remembrance and desires only
the life of this world.
That is their sum of knowledge. Indeed, your Lord is most knowing of who has strayed
from His path, and He is most knowing of who is rightly guided.
Or does man have whatever he wishes? To
Allah belongs whatever is in the heavens and whatever is on the
earth, that He may recompense those who do evil for what they have done and recompense those who do good with the best reward. Those who avoid major sins and immoralities, only committing minor offenses—indeed, your Lord is vast in forgiveness. He is most knowing of you when He produced you from the earth and when you were
fetuses in the wombs of your mothers. So do
not claim yourselves to be pure; He is most knowing.  Who is more pious than he
who turns away and gives a little and withholds? Does he have
knowledge of the unseen, so he sees or does he not know what is in the scriptures of
Moses
and Abraham, who fulfilled his covenant? That no bearer of burdens will bear the burden of
another. And that man shall have nothing
but what he strives for. And that his striving will soon be seen. Then he will be recompensed with a full
recompense. And that
to your Lord is the final destination. And that it is He who makes [one]
laugh and weep. And that it is He who gives life and causes death. And that He
created the two sexes, male and female,
from a sperm-drop when it is emitted. And that upon Him is the
second creation. And that it is He who enriches and provides. And that He is the
Lord of the stars. And that He destroyed the
people of 'Ad and Thamud, leaving none remaining, and
the people of Noah before them. Indeed, they were more unjust and more tyrannical. And the earth was covered with what covered it. So which of the favors of your
Lord do you deny?
This is a warner from the first warnings. The approaching Hour is imminent. There is
none besides God who can avert it. So at
this statement do you wonder and
laugh and
not weep, while
you are heedless? So
prostrate to God and
worship God.
God is greater.
God is greater. So
the Hour has come and the wine has split. And if they see, they turn away and
say  They persisted in their deception and
followed their desires, and
every matter is settled. And there came to them news
containing a deterrent, a profound wisdom, so they died. The warnings
turned away from them on the Day when the caller calls to something
unknown.
God is the Greatest.
God hears those who praise Him.
God is the Greatest. I seek forgiveness from God. God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest.
God is the Greatest.
Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, Master of the
Day of Judgment. You alone we worship, and You alone we ask for help. Guide us to the
straight path, the
path of those upon whom You have bestowed favor, not of those who have incurred [Your] wrath,
nor of those who are astray.
Amen. On the Day when the
caller calls to something unknown, their eyes will be blinded. They will emerge from the
graves as if they were swarming locusts, hastening towards the caller. The
disbelievers will say, "This is a
difficult Day. The people of Noah denied before them, and they denied Our servant and
said, 'He is mad and has gone astray.' So he called upon his Lord, 'Indeed, I am overwhelmed, so help me.' So
We opened the gates of heaven with pouring water and caused the
earth to gush forth with springs, and the waters met for a matter already decreed. And We carried him on a vessel of planks and a covering, which
sails among us as a
recompense for him who
had disbelieved. And
we left it as a sign, so is there anyone who will remember? So
taste My punishment. And how  My punishment and warnings were indeed a warning, and We have certainly made
the Quran easy for remembrance. So is there any who will remember? The people of 'Ad denied the warnings, so how severe was My punishment and warning? Indeed, We sent
upon them a furious wind on a day of continuous misfortune, tearing
people up as if they were uprooted palm trunks.
[Clears throat] So taste My punishment and warnings, and We have certainly made the
Quran easy for remembrance. So is there any who will remember? The people of Thamud denied the warnings, so how severe was My punishment and
warning? And We have certainly made the Quran easy for
remembrance. So is there any who will remember? The people of Thamud denied the warnings, so
they said, "Should we follow a single human being from among ourselves? Indeed, we would then be in
error and madness. And the message was sent down upon him from among us. Rather, he is an
evil liar. They will know tomorrow who is the evil liar."
[Clears throat] They unleashed the trumpet as a trial for them. So watch them and be patient with them and inform
them that the water is
divided between them, each drinking from it is due. So they called their companion, and he took up the task and hamstrung them.
So how severe was My punishment and warning? And We have certainly made
the Quran easy for remembrance. So is there any who will remember? Indeed, We
sent upon them a single blast, and they became like
chaff.  The dying one,
how severe was My punishment and My warnings! And We have certainly made the Qur'an easy
for remembrance, so is there any who will remember? The people of Lot denied the warnings. The people of
Lot denied the warnings. Indeed, We sent upon them a storm of stones,
except for the family of Lot, whom We saved by the light of Our favor. Thus do We reward those who are
grateful. And He overtook them in the morning with a lasting punishment. And He warned them of Our punishment, but they disputed the warnings. And they sought to seduce him concerning his guests, so We blinded their eyes. So taste My punishment and My warnings!
And He overtook them in the morning with a lasting punishment. So taste My punishment and My
warnings! And We have certainly made the Qur'an easy for
remembrance, so is there any who will remember? And the warnings came to the people of Pharaoh, but they said, "Are we to be good tidings?" They denied all
Our signs, so We seized them with the seizure of the Mighty, the
Powerful. Are your disbelievers better than those? Or do you have immunity
in the scriptures? Or do they say, "We are all victorious"? The multitude will be defeated, and they will turn their backs. Rather, the
Hour is their appointed time, and
the Hours are their appointed time and command. Indeed, the criminals are in error and madness. The
Day they are dragged into the Fire on their faces,
so beware of the touch of Hell. Indeed, We have created everything in precise measure, and We have not
commanded  Except for one, in the blink of an eye, and
every [clearing of the throat] is something they did in the scriptures. And
We have destroyed your followers, so is there any who will remember? And everything they
did is in the scriptures, and every small and great thing is recorded. Indeed, for the righteous, indeed, the righteous will be in
gardens and rivers, in a seat of honor near a Sovereign, Perfect in Ability. God is the Greatest. God
hears those who praise Him. Our Lord, God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest. Peace be upon you and
God's mercy. Peace be upon you. God is the Greatest. Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds, the Most
Gracious, the Most Merciful. The religion is You, our Lord. We have
sought refuge in You. The straight path of those upon whom You have bestowed favor, not of those who have evoked [Your] anger or of those who are astray.
Say, He is
God, the One. God, the Eternal Refuge. He neither begets nor is born, nor is there to Him any equivalent. God is the Greatest. God hears those who praise Him. God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest. God is the Greatest. Peace be upon you and God's mercy. Peace be upon you. What God wills. We just did like you know it's like your soul needs food. The soul is just that, that was, beautiful man that needs to be cut up as just Ramadan. This is the new on the day of judgment. The first thing we will be asked about is
our prayer. Now
imagine being part of a project that
teaches thousands of people
around the world how to pray salah
properly for just 100 you can help teach
20 to 60 people like me learn how to
praise and when they teach their
children and their children's children.
[music]